i i have a feeling our next guest will
not be breaking into song but who knows
anything can happen on a wednesday hall
of fame head coach tony dungy joins us
now coach good morning how are you
hey good morning guys good to be with
you what's up coach coach when's the
last time you sang
uh it's uh it's been quite a while i
would say uh
university of minnesota fight song maybe
1977.
coach i know is that is that the truth
is that the roach sings in church i know
he's a singer
it's very easy to blend it's like trust
me it's very easy to blend a bad voice
in with the church crowd singing alone
is a different endeavor all together
you're write my fight song
as a rookie yeah yeah
well um you know and i want to take you
back to that time of the 70s coach
because we've been talking this week
about von miller super bowl 50 mvp his
habit of bringing together pass rushers
from throughout the national football
league to get guys on the same page
about how they apply their trade and i
have to think this is a product of free
agency i can't imagine back in the 70s
lc greenwood and carl ella were hanging
out in the off season comparing notes on
how to sack each other's quarterbacks
no it is a product of free agency and
social media and all that and there's
there's always been camps
offensive guys because quarterbacks have
done it they just don't uh they don't
publicize it you know they talk to each
other about hey how'd you attack this
defense what went well what did you try
to do
and uh you know i think it happens but
not like this where you're saying hey
we're all going to get together and
we're going to get better as a group
of position players
that's a little rare yeah yeah i mean
coach do you find it that you know
you're gonna people are gonna steal
ideas from each other lose the
competitive balance i don't know if you
heard much what we said at the last
segment before you came on but we were
kind of arguing going back and forth and
von miller was kind of trying to say no
all my moves are out there but i was
trying to explain different coaches can
teach different techniques a different
way and you know the lights can pop on
for a player to go oh okay that's how he
does it that's how he's so successful do
you agree with those sentiments am i
wrong there what are your thoughts
well you do want to be careful about
helping other people uh play against you
it does happen all the time i can
remember some of the great conversations
we had on the bus coaching the pro bowl
and you got howie wrong
uh and art still
and you know different guys past rushers
talking about different well this is
what i try to do this is how i set
people up so people talk all the time
but it just is rare to
say you know hey we're going to do this
with
a big big group of people and i'm going
to try to help a bunch of other guys get
better yeah von miller may learn some
things too right that's part of it but i
think if i was on top of my game i'd be
a little hesitant to try to share with
everybody else and help them get better
to beat me
coach yesterday and today the
competition committee talking to teams
about how they are going to claw back at
the new rule making pass interference
subject to replay review in all cases
we're expecting the competition
committee to use this blank check that
they've gotten from ownership to revise
that rule what advice would you give the
competition committee as they embark on
this effort now to to
partially rescind the rule that was
passed in march that all past
interference will be subject to replay
i i just think back to my time on the
committee mike george young was kind of
the sage the old guy on the on the of
the group back then and he used to say
be careful when you let the camel get
his nose under the tent because the tent
is gonna tip over and i think that's
what's gonna happen here that camel is
just gonna keep coming in i've been
watching you know i have fun just going
back watching highlights and videos and
i i've watched some of these playoff
games and super bowls and you see these
touchdown catches and if they're all
going to get reviewed
and is there offensive pushing off is
there a defense that they grabbed
um you know
there were two calls in our championship
game that would have gotten turned
around uh one would have benefited us
and one would have benefited new england
uh but they would have definitely been
turned around if you review past
interference i i just
i think it's gonna be a real real
headache for the league and i think the
the less they can do the less they
review better off they're going to be
well coached so yeah it's the next thing
i want to ask you what do you think the
proper mechanics are to execute the new
reviewing of the pass interference do
you want to see challenge another
challenge flag in coach's hands or do
you want to see the nfl control this and
and be up in the booth and and uh kind
of buzz down to say oh we need to look
at this and then be in control of the
situation
yeah it's a it's a tough call because um
you know that one way you could do it is
say okay scoring plays uh automatically
get reviewed and so if a guy catches a
touchdown pass it's going to be reviewed
and you could
put the pass
segment of it in that but the balls that
aren't caught you know can can be an
issue right i was watching one game uh
it was a monday night game i was
coaching tampa bay bucks we're playing
the minnesota viking jacquez green
catches a touchdown pass in the back of
the end zone
al michaels and everybody they're
looking at it did he really hold on to
the ball
well
if you look at it closely it probably
wasn't a catch but then again on the
replay he got grabbed before the ball
got there yeah what do you do in that
situation they ruled as a touchdown on
the field it really wasn't a touchdown
but there should have been past
interference i think you're going to
have a lot of these kind of issues that
nobody anticipated before great point
and coach one thing you were alarmed by
over the weekend and we were too the
comments from competition committee
chairman rich mckay
that they tell the officials to
officiate hail mary plays differently
for pass interference than regular plays
that that what is past interference the
rest of the game all of a sudden isn't
past interference i don't see anything
in the rule book that invokes the hail
mary standard i this to me is is as
jarring as anything i've heard the nfl
admit to because they're basically
saying there's a second set of rules
that that they just secretly enforce
among themselves
and that was always the competition when
i was coaching and maybe that's being
done and maybe they have always told the
officials that but if that's the case
tell me that as a coach so i can coach
it that way don't officiate a certain
way but i don't know it
and and to me i don't know how you can
do that i don't know how you can say hey
we're going to review past interference
in the end zone
except on hail mary plays
that doesn't make sense at all i think
you you if you tell the officials that
then you do lead into the new orleans
ram situation where hey it's late in the
game and it's not a hail mary but do i
really want to call this uh no we'll let
the players decide on the field uh to me
if it's a penalty if it's in the
rulebook you've got to enforce it
whether it's hail mary player or not and
terry mccauley had the best comment
you know past interference is materially
impacting someone's ability to catch the
ball and you can't do that uh whether
it's the first level the last play yeah
okay we can have a debate for us you
know if there's five guys around
materially influencing some but if you
see it you've got to call it and if
you've got this replay system in place
and you see it on replay then you have
to enforce it in my opinion yeah i'm
with you all the way there coach i
really am okay another like huge
discussion this week that's kind of
popping up and it seems like the nfl is
inching towards this conversation
your thoughts on an 18-game regular
season schedule
i think it would be a mistake i think
one of the things that's great about the
nfl now
is every game matters you've got these
tight races 16 games is a lot you want
to get into the playoffs you want people
to be
ready to play right meaningful games in
january i'm watching the nba playoffs
now and you see the effect of this long
season yes kawhi leonard limping up and
down the floor right kevin durant out
yeah thompson may be out that's not what
people want to see in the playoffs
you're right i have to think you know we
would get some of the same thing if you
add more games and i i just i don't
think it would be good for the players i
don't think it'd be good for the product
you know phil sims was on chris's
podcast yesterday thinking the players
will want it once they see how much
money they will make from those extra
games once they have the numbers put in
front of them do you think players would
be you know that willing to take the
extra money if it means putting
themselves in a position where they
would be banged up i mean players are
wired a different way than us because
they still think they can do anything
and everything would that money lure the
players to do it if they ever had that
put in front of them in in raw dollars
and cents
well i think that's the whole of
everybody who's pushing this 18 game
season that that the kind of greed
factor will kick in and everybody right
now when you say 18 games everybody says
oh no no no no but if it means x number
of thousands of dollars more for each
player then you will get guys that say i
can do that i can play two more uh and
make that money i don't think it would
be good but i think that it would sway
the the bar a little bit and guys would
think about well i can do it for for
that yeah
coach there's been a possibility that
was mentioned from time to time and it's
still lurking out there and i think
there are some people in the league
office that are intrigued by this the
idea of expanding to 18 regular season
games but limiting all players except
quarterbacks and specialists to 16.
has a coach
what what kind of what kind of
chest pains would something like that
cause
you would adjust to that um coaches
adjust to everything but i'll tell you
what the gambling aspect of it now there
will just be a lot of things in place
okay i'm going to rest my guys in games
where i think we're going to win but
we're favored by eight and we win by
three
um you know i i just think there's a lot
of things in place when you start
numbing guys i'm on the whole which two
games am i gonna hold peyton manning out
of um
which two games is tom brady not gonna
play right um i i just
i don't know how how you could really do
that and
um
you know as a coach i'm trying to win
and
i come down to the do i have to save my
guys the last couple of games in case we
have to win them um
so what if you have what if you have
injuries during the week at practice how
do you balance those things out there's
just too many things that i think would
cause problems
right right
well i'll tell you what the nfl is
determined
go ahead
the competition committee has always
talked about balancing the level playing
field and making everything fair and you
know that's why we have the
uh you know 53-man squads non-practice
squads but you can only dress certain
amount of people because they want
everybody to have the same
uh
opportunity to feel players and win
games i think we're
getting into that it would be very
difficult
to make it fair week in and week out for
both sides right
and coach we're with you i mean i think
18 games is too much but i also feel
like that that the dollars and cents are
going to push this thing and push this
thing until
it becomes inevitable and and who knows
how long that will take thanks as always
for some of your time and we hope uh to
talk to you real soon
all right sounds good you guys have fun
the rest of the day huh be good coach
the man there is hall of fame head coach
tony dunn
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports